you guys remember my review for
abduction the film starring Taylor
Lautner and Lily Collins every time she
spoke of this movie like it's like it's
like each sentence and then with a duck
face it's Taylor
save me when Mir Mir came out I was like
wow she didn't make the face even one
time good job well with Mortal
Instruments City of Bones the face has
returned the Mortal Instruments the City
of Bones is directed by the guy behind
the Pink Panther 2 and agent Cody Banks
this is Hollywood's latest attempt to
adapt a book into a successful franchise
now in this movie we have Lily Collins
she plays a young girl who becomes aware
of the supernatural war that's going on
she finds out that her actual parents
actually aren't her actual parents too
many actually is in that sentence I
apologize she meets a boy who introduces
her into this world and she learns of
this magical cup that everyone seems to
be after now I really wasn't looking
forward to this movie because it really
just looks like the next thing that's
trying to be Twilight and a lot of
people on Twitter told me it's
definitely not Twilight the book has
nothing like Twilight it's not like
Twilight at all and I can tell you this
movie is definitely better than Twilight
in fact for the first like half hour
this movie I was pretty into it I was
really surprised how well done it was I
was getting more interested in the
actual story and it was pretty exciting
and then it turned in to Twilight I'm
sorry guys I didn't read the book maybe
it's nothing like Twilight but Screen
Gems the company that put this movie
into theaters yeah I think they want the
next flight I think it was right around
the time where the girl and the boy were
in the green house at night and they
started kissing and then a pop song
started playing as they kissed and then
the sprinkler system turned on and
showered them with rain I'm pretty sure
was right about that time that I lost
interest in this movie I'm not even
kidding that's actually in the movie I
was sitting there just like the movie
started out really cool it was exciting
it was fun there was this great sequence
with this dog that I won't get into
because it was probably the best part of
the movie and then it just turned into
this really cliched teen romance for the
supernatural element in there with a
love triangle with a girl who is
introduced by a boy to another
supernatural
and then there are various reasons why
they can't be together even though they
want to be together it is the exact same
formula as Twilight this movie also
suffers from the same thing that Percy
Jackson suffered from it all feels very
derivative it feels like it's a total
copy off of other things there are
elements in this movie that were just
100% Star Wars it's not like a copy off
Twilight yes there are actual vampires
and actual werewolves that fight and
they're badass in this movie even though
the CGI is kind of subpar there are cool
sequences with these creatures they're
not these lovey W little things but the
central formula of this movie is the
same formula as Twilight and I can't
escape that it's a fact
and maybe the book wasn't like that but
it's definitely clear that this movie is
trying to emulate the same success that
Twilight had and hopefully kickstart
another franchise similar to Twilight
this month seems to be the odd title
month I don't really understand what's
going on paranoia
no one's paranoid in that movie in this
movie the City of Bones isn't it for
like two minutes and they never really
reference it again it's in there for
like two seconds and it's like okay I
guess it's called the City of Bones
because it exists so there are good
things about the movie Lily Collins
isn't awful in the movie even though she
has that sort of I'm definitely in a
movie right now and I'm gonna make a
cool acting face thing going on where
it's all slo-mo and I don't know it's
just like she wasn't bad she wasn't
terrible she didn't make that face she
makes a lot where she's like the comic
relief in the movie is her one friend
who's the third guy in the love triangle
that has to be there the one guy who
definitely likes her who doesn't get all
the affection that he wants he kind of
annoy me in the movie even though he was
there to be the comic relief or the guy
who's like experiencing all this for the
first time and he has to say what the
audience is thinking I just kept seeing
all these various tropes these films
have done over and over again and what
started out promising just got
squandered and I really feel like the
movie started out like something that
could have been pretty cool but then it
just became very clichéd I will say that
Jonathan Rhys Meyers is very good in the
movie I like him quite a bit he gives a
pretty good performance as this guy
Valentine I really liked him in the
movie I thought he did a good job there
are certain elements of this movie that
are good Lena Headey is pretty good in
the film also like you can see people
are trying to do well with this movie
but it just doesn't have that
originality or the focus that this movie
needs to have also
just seems like we're in this time now
where everyone thinks it's boring to do
a wide still shot of action that's not
boring I mean audience members will go
to it and be like wait wait what that's
a wide shot of people fighting I don't
like this this feels weird because
they're not used to that anymore
everyone has to have this close-up shaky
in your face thing because that's the
trend now just stop doing that okay go
watch the Empire Strikes Back where Luke
and Vader are fighting on a catwalk it's
just one shot still on moving and it's
fantastic okay it's a classic movie it's
like every director in Hollywood forgot
how to film a wide shot I don't
understand what's going on The Mortal
Instruments the City of Bones is not a
terrible movie don't get me wrong I was
interested from time to time it has some
cool sequences in it but what started
out strong and had some strong points
throughout the way was messed up by this
really convoluted mythology and this
definite Twilight trying to be Twilight
thing and it just got on my nerves I'm
gonna give the Mortal Instruments City
of Bones a C+ so guys did you read the
book do you think the book is pretty
cool are you tired of Hollywood taking
cool books and making it into crap cuz I
can imagine you probably are if you read
this book or Percy Jackson as always
guys thanks very much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]